[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
société pas de viande ni de poisson ni
de fruits de mer depuis le 1er novembre
toutes les cantines scolaires de la
maternelle à la terminale doivent
proposer au moins une fois par semaine
un menu végétarien
cette nouvelle mesure est inscrite dans
la loi et galim une mesure qui divise
parfois pour évoquer ce sujet avec nous
ce soir en plateau jeanine marie
première adjointe au maire en charge de
l'éducation attrape bonsoir bonsoir
cécilia fabre diététicienne
nutritionniste sur la commune de saint
cyr l'école
bonsoir et enfin laurent gaillard vous
êtes le représentant des yvelines de
l'association végétarienne de france
bonsoir courgettes au curry lasagnes aux
légumes couscous avec des boulettes de
sarrasin elle les écoliers ont droit à
un menu végétarien au moins une fois par
semaine depuis le 1er novembre dans les
établissements publics comme privés de
la maternelle à la terminale pas de
viande ni de poisson ni de fruits de mer
mais les oeufs et les produits laitiers
sont acceptés une fois par semaine c'est
assez laurent gaillard alors une fois
par semaine c'est le strict minimum fait
le strict minimum
le volet alimentation je le laissais
cécilia puisqu'elle est et éthicienne
donc c'est son domaine
je crois qu'il faut comprendre quels
sont les enjeux de ce menu végétarien
alors au niveau de la consommation de
viande on mange beaucoup trop de viande
en france dans le monde en règle
générale puisqu'on est à peu près à 85
86 kg chez nous et il va falloir qu'on
divise notre consommation de viande pour
atteindre une vingtaine de kilos par an
la moyenne mondiale est de 40 kg lui
apportons des sandales 20 kg pour une
raison très simple c'est que d'abord il
ya un problème de santé
encore une fois ces cigales à pouvoir
nous en parler mais un problème
environnemental qui est très sérieux
parce que l'industrie de la viande est
une des industries les plus polluantes
les plus émettrices à en termes de gaz à
effet de serre
et il va falloir qu'on les réduisent de
façon drastique parce qu'on parle de
stratégie cat c'est à dire que pour
pouvoir parvenir à ce fameux degré
singles dont on parle il va falloir
qu'on parvient à diminuer nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de quasiment 50%
45 ans en 2030 pour arriver une
neutralité carbone en 2050
ça veut dire que pour un français qui
aimait 12 tonnes 12 tonnes de gaz à
effet de serre par an il va falloir
qu'il en soit à 2 or 2 tonnes
c'est exactement ce qu'est votre
alimentation ce que représente notre
alimentation
donc vous proposez quoi deux fois par
semaine ce menu végétarien comme la fcpe
le souhaite alors deux menus végétariens
ce serait très bien qui pourrait être
construit autour de protéines
essentiellement végétale par exemple un
dalle de lentilles jouer un couscous de
légumes un deuxième qui peut-être a
effectivement une pizza végétarienne
avec du fromage et une option et jettent
ariane les autres jours de la semaine
mais pour revenir effectivement encore
une fois sur ces fameuses de tonnes que
représente notre alimentation c'est
savoir que 89 % de ses émissions sont
dues aux produits animaux et 75% pour
les bovins et les produits laitiers
donc effectivement c'est un minimum
strict minimum ce menu ensuite un
deuxième ce serait déjà une bonne avance
est beaucoup plus conforme aux
recommandations internationales et avec
une option les autres jours de la
semaine qui effectivement permettrait
aussi de résoudre le problème du sang
port et du sans viande qui effectivement
toujours un petit peu teinté de petits
problèmes alors jeanne-marie attrape
aujourd'hui les élèves ont mangé
betteraves sofres balsamique
en plat une omelette au fromage et
pinard et pâtes en grattant et en
dessert un yaourt nature est une pomme
c'est donc un menu végétarien et hier
les enfants avaient des tomates en
entrée et en plat des lentilles et inoa
à la provençale
mais un deuxième choix était possible
pour les écoles élémentaires uniquement
des lasagnes au boeuf c'est donc un
repas végétarien imposé comme le veut la
loi mais également un autre plat si les
enfants le désirent alors nous on avait
commencé bien avant tout ça donc on a
continué sur la perspective que nous
n'osions tracé à savoir que depuis
l'année dernière des gens faisait du
du végétarien une fois par mois depuis
longtemps et puis l'année dernière on a
expérimenté les mini self pour le plat
principal de façon a effectivement
proposé du végétarien ceux qui ne
mangeait pas de viande mais c'était
aussi en parallèle pour éviter tous les
petits problèmes
alex de soi disant allergies de viande
qui n'existe pas sauf si une prise de
sang est le marqueur cng 3 c'est assez
rare et surtout pour enlever la pression
des familles sur les enfants par rapport
à tu mange pas de viande qu'ils mangent
pas de viande on entendait ça sur le
parcours de l'école excusez moi mais bon
un moment donné faut pas lâcher la
pression aussi donc le fait d'avoir le
choix entre un menu végétarien et puis
ceux qui veulent de la viande peuvent le
faire la régler tous les problèmes
voilà c'est aucune et sur toutes les
écoles depuis le 1er septembre
c'est donc une révolution dans
l'assiette des élèves quand on leur
propose un steak végétal composé de
petits pois vous pensez que ça leur
plaît autant qu'un steak haché frites
traditionnelles
j'ai envie de dire ça dépend des goûts
voilà faut les enfants sont très
attachés au visuel comme ils sont
attachés au visuel mais on se rend
compte que en leur proposant des choses
différentes en leur expliquant qu si je
pense est ce qu'on vous disait avec
laurent que l'on n'explique pas assez
donc en expliquant en faisant goûter
mais on élargit complètement
le champ des possibles j'ai envie de
dire donc faut pas hésiter à leur
proposer c'est sûr que si l'on reste sur
le tech frites
ils vont vous dire qu'ils aiment que le
steak frites et puis finalement en tout
temps on se rend compte qu'il ya d'autre
chose de sympa quoi alors on va revenir
sur plusieurs termes végétarien
végétalien flexitariens ou encore vegan
comment faire la différence
allez on y va pour un petit
récapitulatif pour nos téléspectateurs
avec vous cécilia fabre diététicienne
nutritionniste flexitariens alors
t'excite à rien moi c'est un peu voilà
ce que je prône parfois on en parlait
avec laurent c'est ont fait un petit peu
de tout voilà on va pas forcément aller
à fond sur le végétal à fond sur
l'animal mais c'est en fait un petit peu
de tout ou c'est autre version du terme
je choisis de faire attention pour x
raison que ce soit santé ou
environnementale à ma consommation de
viandes poissons etc
mais si shore au restaurant si je vais
chez des amis et puis qu'on propose ça
je le mange quand même après
effectivement nous avons le végétarien
qui comme vous l'avez dit au départ va
continuer à consommer des oeufs et des
produits laitiers
les avalanches de badges ait pas de
volaille pas de voile à tous a exigé des
mamans dany d'animaux vraiment entier et
végétaliens voir vegan pousser un peu
plus la chose en enlevant tout ce qui va
être animal mais aussi issus produit des
animaux ou issus de l'agriculture animal
donc je pense barroso au lait qui
viennent des animaux élevés gan vie gan
où il va carrément enlever la laine etc
tous les produits ou produits de la
ruche laurent gaillard vous êtes vous
même végétarien qu'est ce qui a changé
dans votre quotidien
alors ce qui a changé dans mon quotidien
c'est que déjà je me sens beaucoup plus
en accord avec les tic qui est aussi
bien l'éthique animale
qu'environnemental les deux vont de pair
de toute façon puisque effectivement
encore une fois on sera tous amené à
diminuer drastiquement notre
consommation de viande est souvent le
drastiquement n'ai pas bien compris donc
ça c'est le premier point d'un point de
vue la santé je n'en porte vraiment pas
plus mal bien au contraire on s'aperçoit
maintenant effectivement que même des
athlètes de haut niveau
suivent des régimes végétariens ou
végétaliens et néanmoins obtiennent des
performances tout à fait remarquable
puisque récemment encore aux jeux de rio
un athlète l'haltérophile catégorie 75
76 kg était quand même médaille d'or et
il est vegan donc on peut effectivement
avoir du muscle et être être végétarien
les athlètes d'endurance non prouvé
maintes et une fois donc c'est
simplement une façon de pouvoir
effectivement d'un point de vue éthique
se dire je peux très bien passé produits
animaux et être en bonne santé
donc je préfère les laisser tranquilles
et ensuite pour l'environnement c'est le
levier le plus efficace que l'on n'est
actuellement pour pouvoir diminuer nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
plus efficace comme vous 5 % des
français sont végétariens ou végétaliens
d'après une étude la restauration
collective se plaint d'absence de corpus
de recettes adaptées pour les menus
végétariens attrape vous avez une
commission menus pour élaborer ses robes
à la commission menus qui est d'abord
pour les deux ou trois mois qui viennent
les menus avec une diététicienne depuis
toujours et
je les ai jamais rencontré de problème
particulier à montigny certains enfants
participent à ces commissions pourrait
alors donner titien pas aux commissions
ils ont une formation sur l'équilibré
alimentaire fait par la diététicienne et
les animateurs il participe à
l'élaboration de menus un concours de
menu et le menu qu'à gagner effet sur
toute la ville dans toutes les écoles et
des menus végétariens mais équilibré
c'est possible cecelia fabrice est
possible surtout comme on se disait avec
laurent avant l'émission effectivement
fin on peut très chaud mieux manger
végétarien équilibré plutôt que
conventionnelle classique est
complètement déséquilibrée
surtout que là on est sur un menu en
plus par semaine mais oui on peut tout à
fait équilibré une ration végétarienne
bien proportionné aussi bien en
protéines lipides en glucides et en tout
les vitamines et minéraux ont fait un
petit peu attention quand même à la
vitamine b12 on sait que c'est une des
carences que peuvent présenter nos
patients végétarien on peut
éventuellement supplémenter en général
c'est nous qu'on recommande un
supplément à base de compléments
alimentaires en b12 pour être sûr pas
besoin de l'être de linge etc table à ce
niveau là mais en comprimés ans j'ai lu
ça passe très bien pour être sûr de bien
atteindre nos apports nutritionnels
recommandés et des repas végétariens
imposé au moins une fois par semaine
dans les cantines scolaires est ce une
bonne chose
écoutez les réactions des yvelinois les
enfants ils mangent souvent par beaucoup
de frites os des pattes et pas beaucoup
de légumes text à pois et des
ajustements diversifier les repas et des
idées à la maison après aux parents
c'est bien il pourrait même lui faire
deux fois par semaine
challes les incite à manger plus de
légumes et marques rossoneri c'est une
bonne chose mais est ce que les enfants
sont prêts à ses petits soins
la question c'est surtout la qualité de
ce que mangent les enfants et mangez
végétarien oui mais ce qui compte c'est
surtout manger des produits de qualité
des produits qui sont pas des produits
industriels ça les formes à ce que fait
ainsi plus tard on est des problèmes
avec la viande ou des choses comme ça
inutile peuvent s'adapter à une
alimentation sans viande une fois par
semaine je trouve ça bien plus ce serait
mieux
je serai mieux mais une fois c'est déjà
un sacré pas et elle sera un sacré
changement
on entend beaucoup parler d'une certaine
sensibilisation sur ce type de pratiques
et je pense que ça se démocratise dans
beaucoup de communes donc je pense que
ça serait bien que ce soit fait sur
saint quentin en yvelines sans poisson
se trouve c'est dommage quand même
totalement végétarien après faut pas
qu'ils aient des coups de pompe l'après
midi est-ce que c'est suffisamment en
nourrissant art pas comme ça pour un
enfant pour toute ma journée je suis pas
sur quoi on l'a entendu pas de coup de
fatigue de coup de pompe comme disait
c'est yvelinoise c'est ce que craignent
souvent les personnes effectivement le
coup de pompe enfin encore une fois la
nourriture végétarienne bien bien
équilibrée bien mené vous offre une
quantité de glucides largement suffisant
je veux dire qu'ils sont quand même le
carburant ce qui nous servent pour notre
énergie de des fibres donc qui sont
aussi des aliments qui permet d'être
rassasié donc non si des enfants mangent
ce qui est dans l'assiette
il n'y a pas de problème sachez que
quand même 50 % du gâchis alimentaire
c'est la viande le poisson qui est jetée
50% le gâchis alimentaire est absolument
astronomiques sur la planète c'est 30%
de notre alimentation qui est jeté et
dans la restauration scolaire
essentiellement les produits carnés et
les poissons donc il n'y a absolument
aucune inquiétude à avoir quant aux
baisses d'énergie ou un coup de pompe
quand on a un repas végétarien dans
l'assiette et qu'on a mangé le tout ces
demandes
vous confirmez alors le coup de pompe
souvent vient pas du tout effectivement
de d'un repas qui serait plus de ce type
là est au contraire on est souvent plus
riches en glucides et bons glucides
qu'on appelait autrefois sucre lent
qu'on appelle plus comme ça qu'on
appelle glucides complexes
voilà le coup de pompe bien souvent
d'une mauvaise régulation de la glycémie
à des patients à moi qui nous écoutent
ils sont entendus ça en long en large et
en travers
on fait tout ça avec nos glycémie
journalière est bien le coup de pompe
qui vient quand on a la petite
hypoglycémie réactionnelle mais ça ça
vient pas d'un côté des protéines en
fait c'est je mange quelque chose de
très sucré d'un coup index glycémique oh
et puis je redescends d'un coup il a
effectivement à parer le coup de pompe
donc le coup de pompe vraiment comme on
peut le ressentir vers 10h30 11h en
général en france avec les petits
déjeuners qu'on a ne vient pas d'un
problème d'apport en protéines quelque
chose de végétariens d'une protéine
végétale ou animale
il est certain qu'on coûte que sur les
faits rassasiant oui on sait très bien
c'est les protéines qui vont venir nous
caler mais aussi les fibres donc là on
aura quand même des protéines on aura
aussi d'autres plus de fibres donc d'un
point de vue rassasiement satiété on
n'aura pas de souci et je dirais même
plus que du coup on aura peut-être moins
de coups de pompe puisque les fibres en
fait on plaint de propriétés
extraordinaires mais aussi et surtout
celle de limiter l'absorption du gras et
du sucre alimentaire pour lentilles dire
et d'absorber plus ou moins l'eau ont du
coup elles vont mieux réguler ce qu'on
appelle les glycémie postprandiale c'est
à dire les glycémies qui suivent leur
pain donc du coup on va avoir une
meilleure régulation de ces glycémie
postprandiale donc on va avoir tendance
justement à peut-être avoir moins de
poufs due à une hypoglycémie
réactionnelle on sera de toute façon
calais puisqu'on aura eu un minimum
d'apport en protéines on sera bien riche
en fibres les eux reviennent souvent
dans ses menus est ce qu'il ya un
problème de réglementation à ce jour on
avait dans l'ancienne diététique des
recours même sur nos patients
hypertriglycéridémies en hyper
cholestérol ils ont à nous dire
attention à leurs yeux et leurs fromages
et on a fait une étude on a fait deux
cohortes une lèvre des fromages et
l'autre on leur a laissé ton nous a dit
ok en fait le résultat est le même donc
fait leur la paix y laisser leur leur et
le fromage donc non pas de souci quels
sont les retours que vous avez eu jamie
de marit sur ses repas végétariens quand
je pose la question mais pas les voir
tout de suite les effets d'année
et les enfants étaient satisfaits et
soulagés d'un côté puisqu'il ya eu plus
la présence de la viande halal dans
l'eau dans la queue dans l'assiette
et lorsqu'on fait la chasse au gaspi
puisqu'il ya dans les écoles maintenant
le pesage de de ce qui va ce ski est
jetée on s'aperçoit que c'est en baisse
régulière et notamment cette année avec
la mise en place des mini self pour le
plat principal
donc c'est positif les enfants sont très
satisfaits et le coup de pompe qui vient
surtout de ce qu'on a absorbé le matin
au petit déjeuner voilà on l'avait eu la
discussion ici le petit déjeuner ça peut
être un verre d'eau un verre de lait ou
alors un repas comme moi j'en connais
qui font un voile à la qualité c'est pas
forcément la quantité mais la qualité de
ce que l'on mangé comme les enfants du
monde route ça je crois que c'est
vraiment très important parce que
actuellement on mange 60% protéines
animales 40 % végétale il faudrait
inverser déjà cette tendance dans un
premier temps et ensuite mettre
justement au coeur de l'assiette des
légumineuses qui sont à la fois riche en
protéines et en fibres et qui ont un
indice glycémique très bas et qui
épinglent exactement et un indice
qu'encore une fois glycémique très bas
qui permettent précisément d'éviter ces
coups de pompe
donc elles ont vraiment tout l'hiver 59%
des français sont favorables à
l'introduction des repas végétariens
dans les cantines scolaires une posture
plus marquée chez les jeunes générations
74 % des 18-34 ans sont favorables à ce
que ces repas soient proposés dans les
cantines donc c'est des personnes 18 34
ans un peu plus jeune est ce qu on veut
parler d'effet générationnel je pense je
pense
puis de communication surtout c'est fait
je crois que les gens sont tout à fait
conscients de ce qui se passe sur la
planète
sa patte toujours comment réagir mais
leur offre
la réaction il adhère à cette réaction
lots sur la ville on est en train de
travailler le labo le le label eco sa
requête un label de qualité bio qui fait
des circuits courts on est déjà dedans
les produits locaux en est déjà dedans
donc bon ça devrait se passer sans
problème mais on est tout à fait dans
cette nouvelle volonté d'aller dans ce
sens là et l'éducation que peu aux
enfants va aussi dans ce sens elle les
élèves mangent entre deux et quatre fois
trop de viande dans les cantines avec ce
repas végétariens les protéines animales
sont remplacés par des protéines
végétales ou céréales
vous pensez que par ce biais les enfants
se poseront des questions sur la
réduction des protéines carnet cécilia
fabre ça dépend de l'âge et puis j'ai
envie de dire expliquons aussi parce que
c'est ce qu'on évoque avec laurent je
suis pas convaincu qu'il y en ait
beaucoup qui remarque surtout s'ils sont
plus petits je pense voilà vous gêne
élémentaire mon lait maternel en parlons
pas mais je suis pas convaincu que on
bâtit lité que tient là il n'ya pas de
gens n'y a pas de poisson
donc c'est bien beau de faire quelque
chose mais faut leur expliquer falloir
attirer l'attention pour leur dire tiens
à ce que terna et puis expliquer la
démarche expliquer la raison toujours 20
voile a expliqué expliqué il faut font
parler quoi elle les plus grands se
positionne 34% des français sont
flexitariens ils ont globalement diminué
leur consommation de viande et de
poisson vous en parliez tout à l'heure
laurent gaillard vous pensez que c'est à
cause de la production de viande
industrielle alors la production de
viande industrielle est absolument
incontournable compte tenu des volumes
que l'on consomme en france c'est 80 %
de notre production 95% des porcs sont
élevés sur caillebotis 83% des poulets
de chair 68% des poules pondeuses 99%
des lapins c'est absolument colossal
donc effectivement cette ces animaux là
il faut les nourrir dont ça demande
énormément aussi de quantité de
nourriture je veux dire que en france
par exemple la moitié des céréales que
l'on produites sont partent à
l'exportation sur l'autre moitié
vous en avez 30 % qui sont données
nos 10 % pour les êtres humains donc
trois fois moins et 10% pour les
agrocarburants au niveau mondial tout le
monde s'est ému de voir l'amazone y
brûlé récemment c'est oublier un peu
vite que malheureusement là l'europe est
le deuxième importateur mondial de soja
brésilien que la france qu'on passe 3
millions de tonnes par an et que ça sert
essentiellement à nourrir 50 % la
volaille 24 % de nos ports 16 % de nos
vaches
donc effectivement on a eu tous une
empreinte forêt externalisée de 350 m²
par français 60% à cause du soja qui
encore une fois nourris des animaux donc
c'est un gâchis invraisemblable de
ressources
c'est une source de pollution
insoutenable et effectivement ce
flexitarisme dont on parle sera efficace
si jamais on a des ordres de grandeur en
tête qui nous permette effectivement de
voir ce que c'est exactement que de
réduire sa consommation de viande
là encore placé 2,86 à une vingtaine de
kilos c'est très conséquent et c'est à
ça qu'il va falloir préparer les gens et
d'éducation et à l'école est là pour çà
également elle a son rôle à jouer et ce
menu végétarien permet effectivement
enfin de pouvoir aborder cette
problématique la viande justement c'est
ce qui coûte souvent le plus cher dans
les repas avec ses menus végétariens ce
que le coût des repas a diminué à
trappes
il a augmenté ses confrères puisque
l'offre de la qualité voilà et la viande
que l'on que l'on sert aux enfants c'est
de la viande que l'on va choisir sur sur
pied dans une ferme
even in one et trois mois après où
quatre mois ou six mois
elle est consommée donc on sait et sont
nourris essentiellement avec des
végétaux
donc on sait on sait exactement ce qu'on
met dans l'assiette mais les enfants
mieux fait la différence
et du côté des producteurs alors sacs
faits maison donc ça change un peu la
donne et du côté des producteurs des
agriculteurs alors c'est une perte pour
eux moi je pense pas je pense qu'ils s'y
retrouvent de la même manière un nom
entre le crois pas
madoff le fait de mettre en circuit
court aussi que yahia un gars quand même
à on paye la qualité mais on les
gagnants sur le transport puisque il ya
le transport en moi et puis puis bon on
souhaite qu'on met dans l'assiette des
enfants
c'est ça je crois qu'il est essentiel
cette expérimentation donc de deux ans
de la loi et galim fait l'objet d'une
évaluation notamment vous l'aurez
compris de son impact sur le gaspillage
alimentaire sur les taux de
fréquentation et sur le coût des repas
dont les résultats seront transmis au
parlement au plus tard six mois avant
son terme
dernière question avant de clôturer
cette émission le temps de restauration
à la cantine est il un bon vecteur pour
faire évoluer les mentalités va faire un
petit tour de table on a commencé par
vous oui je pense que ça peut être un
bon vecteur on a on a une bonne base non
et enfin voilà il ya des lois à faire
respecter pour établir les menus il ya
toujours un diététicien qui est derrière
que ce soit pour l' équilibre que ce
soit pour le respect des lois que ce
soit pour l'hygiène aussi en cuisine on
fait des audits
voilà on peut être amené à appeler les
services veto s'il ya quelque chose en
forme le personnel ont fait beaucoup de
choses mais encore une fois je pense
qu'il faudrait aller vraiment voir les
élèves
on va passer voir les élèves on reste
malheureusement que les moyens qu'on
abat dans nos mairies ou en prestation
de services à faire les menus et jamais
ils ont une notion que bahia un
diététicien derrière de ce qui se passe
donc oui ça peut être un bon vecteur
mais je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
faut aller sur le terrain faut aller les
voir faut expliquer faire des ateliers
en classe voilà ça suffit pas et ça
pourrait être un très bon vecteur
jeanine mari dans votre commune attrape
alors loulé la diététicienne rencontre
les enfants puisqu'elle contribue à les
leur apprendre l'équilibré alimentaire
et des premiers menus qui sont ressortis
on a vu apparaître les soupes ce qu'on
n'aurait jamais osé faire
il adore les soupes et les épinards le
chou vert est revenu sur la table et je
pense que à la maison lors aurait offert
saïd redit non donc ces menus
végétariens c'est l'occasion de
découvrir pour votre saveurs en atelier
philosophique où les enfants ont parlé
de manger de la viande ou pas de la
viande viennent avec k qui était tout à
fait on le voyait un carnassier quand
même tous les autres étaient non pas
nuire là c'est en train de prendre nos
forces dans cette jeune génération et on
pourra être surpris à l'avenir à leurs
occasions + 15 ans + 15 ans pour être
patient je me réjouis ça c'est
formidable
j'entends effectivement voyez je suis
sauf que c'est éducatif
il ya effectivement des changements qui
s'opèrent à l'heure actuelle qui sont
nécessaires et c'est réjouissant est
très rassurant de voir qu effectivement
d'un point de vue des professionnels de
l'alimentation que des élus de
d'accueillir sa les bras ouverts de
faire en sorte que ça se passe bien
parce que ça peut être tout à fait
heureux tout à fait joyeux
l'alimentation végétarienne et coûteuse
elle est saine effectivement on peut
aborder des problèmes comme celui de
l'éthique et je crois que tout le monde
allait gagner deux ans vous pensez que
fait assez pour faire évoluer les moeurs
et changer ces mentalités je pense pas
que c'était mentalité il ya des
expériences qu'ils sont quand même bien
ancrée et si on n'a pas la viande on a
l'impression que on est déficitaire de
quelque chose de lourd ça peut être
remplacé par autre chose qu'on a les
idées reçues justement des parents
accompagnant et il est professionnel
parce que nous on est quand même fort
mais très diététique traditionnel à
l'ancienne et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on sache aussi
nous autres diététiciens nutritionnistes
adapté aux nouvelles recommandations
moi j'ai besoin par contre comme sorte
une étude comme quoi oui c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien voie large du factuel
devenu scientifique du médical si on
m'apporte par a plus b que ça peut être
très bien je sais très bien équilibrée
narration comme ça il faut qu'on sache
évoluer qu'on reste pas non mais on m'a
appris viande poisson ou plus légumes
féculents produits laitiers fruits et
matières grasses voilà faut savoir
s'adapter un peu et répondre aussi à la
demande du patient
comment vous lutter contre ces idées
reçues parfois des parents où l'enfant
doit manger de la viande pour grandir
pour sa croissance
on explique on explique que la
croissance ne passe pas que par ça on
explique les besoins j'explique souvent
beaucoup comment fonctionne le
métabolisme aussi parce qu'une fois
qu'on a compris comment le métabolisme
fonctionnel plus bel exemple que j'ai
c'est votre corps c'est un animal il
veut survivre si vous le privé et que
vous lui mettez des restrictions est ce
que vous pensez vraiment qu'il allait
perdre ses réserves
en plus de ça alors qu'on lui donne pas
non et quand toi là on leur donne plein
de petites images comme ça pour
comprendre comment ça fonctionne on
casse plus comme ça les idées reçues
plutôt que de leur ballon c'est non
c'est pas vrai oui c'est vrai voilà si
on explique balles dans le corps humain
on sort des études on argumente on donne
des images un peu comme faisait une
super émission quand on était petit la
vie de la vie ça c'était voilà quand on
donne plein d'image comme ça
ça va mieux when i'm on arrive mieux à
casser les idées reçues comme ça plutôt
qu'en rentrant pleine balle en leur
disant oui c'est bien vraiment c'est pas
bien quoi oui c'est bien dans ces bas
bien on porte des jugements exactement
et voilà qu'ils passent devant la migros
6 2 quel que soit l'âge de choisir sa
thérapeutique avec l'accord des parents
lorsqu on est mineur jusqu'à 16 ans mais
à nous aussi professionnels de santé
tant qu au niveau médical on sait ce
qu'on fait est que on a jugé de l'état
du patient et si c'est possible ou pas à
nous aussi d'entendre leur demande leurs
desiderata et de mettre en place ce
qu'il faut pour répondre à leurs
demandes et leurs envies avec de la
sécurité mais il faut pas non plus non
l'équilibré salée puisque tu veux je
m'en fiche quoi faut savoir s'ouvrir un
petit peu et faire au mieux pour le
patient en étant toujours dans la santé
merci merci à tous d'avoir participé à
cette émission est à vous nous regardez
c'est la fin de ce set une société très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]